(energetic music)
What drove world famous designer Kate Spade
to apparently take her own life?
The mystery deepens as we begin to unravel the clues.
Yeah, and some are wondering was her marriage to blame.
The answers may be found in a disturbing note
that Spade left behind.
Kate Spade projected an image
of happiness and success.
Hi, I'm Kate Valentine Spade.
But a source tells ET
the designer dealt with depression for years
and tried desperately to hide it,
quote, "She truly cared about her brand,
"and didn't want the public to know of her pain."
Kate's husband, Andy Spade, told the New York Times
today that her death was a shock.
He also revealed that he and Kate
had been living separately for the past 10 months,
and quote, "She was actively seeking help
"for depression and anxiety over the last five years,
"seeing a doctor on a regular basis,
"and taking medication for both depression and anxiety."
Police say Kate hanged herself with a scarf
while her daughter was at school,
and she left behind a note.
The contents of that note,
as well as physical state of the apartment,
and the comments of the witness
lend to the credibility that it is an apparent suicide.
According to TMZ, the note had this message
to Kate's 13-year-old daughter, Francis Beatrix,
Bea, I have always loved you.
This is not your fault.
Ask daddy.
Comedian David Spade paid tribute
to his sister-in-law Kate by posting
two of his favorite photos with her,
one at a book signing, another at Christmas time.
He captioned both, it's a rough world out there people,
try to hang on.
And Kate's niece, the actress Rachel Brosnahan,
shared this sweet video of Kate dancing with her husband.
She wrote, knowing Katy, this is how
she would want to be remembered.
Hug your loved ones extra tight today.
It's terribly, terribly tragic.
And Hollywood is mourning Kate Spade's death.
Actresses loved her bright and cheery designs.
I loved her work.
First handbag I ever bought was a Kate Spade handbag
so
I just think it's a,
what can you say?
I've worn her clothes so much,
both in person and on my show The Mindy Project.
It's so sad.
All I can think about is prayers
for her daughter and her husband.
I'm not even at the place to think about legacy.
Well, all I do is think about her child
and those that she left behind,
and it's just a tragedy.
(energetic music)